So today we're gonna continue talking about imaging.
Last Tuesday on Tuesday I talked mainly about about imaging using x-rays and the
conventional sort of x ray,
which a chest x Ray,
which leads to a projected image.
And so you understand the limitations of,
of projected images and from x-ray's,
something about the physics of how an x ray image is formed based on,
uh,
x rays passing through your body.
And depending on what tissues,
what types of tissues the xray passes through,
some of that extra energy will be absorbed and therefore only a fraction of it
is available to pass all the way through your body and expose the x ray film.
And we're going to talk about several alternate forms of imaging today,
many of which are similar to CT imaging.
Now CT imaging as a special form of x ray imaging,
where you rotate the source of x rays and the detector around the object you're
trying to image around the patient and you take images at a large number of
angles and using mathematical approaches,
you reconstruct the three dimensional image from those multiple.
Okay,
two dimensional,
um,
projections,
right?
And that mathematical process is called reconstruction from back projections and
um,
and it results in a three dimensional image in a CT,
a slice of the,
of the,
um,
of the object of the patient is obtained by rotating the source and the detector
around that axial location.
What we're going to start with is talking about an alternate to,
uh,
to Ct.
What happened?
Did it go out?
It was on at the
beginning.
Right.
Okay.
Um,
we're going to talk about an alternate to,
uh,
to CT that doesn't use,
okay.
It's there.
It's there but not good.
Is it?
Yeah.
Sorry.
It's just take me a minute here.
Hopefully.
Is that look better?
Well,
we'll go with it anyway.
All right.
It looks a lot better.
Okay.
We're going to talk about an alternate to CT,
which forms the same kind of images that is images of an axial location,
maybe a transverse image,
a slice from the body.
Um,
we'll be imaged using a technique called magnetic resonance as an alternative
to,
uh,
to using x rays.
And we talked last time about one of the problems with x rays that x-ray's had a
lot of beneficial qualities for making images.
They pass through tissues,
they allow you to look inside their absorbed selectively by tissues have
different density.
They're able to expose x ray film and all of those properties make them uh,
very good for uh,
for forming images.
The problem is that x-rays x ray radiation is a form of ionizing radiation.
It can,
uh,
that can cause damage to cells and tissues in the body.
And so one has to be careful about how much dose you expose a particular patient
to in magnetic resonance image imaging,
use magnetic fields and radio frequency radiation non-ionizing forms of
radiation in order to,
in order to form an image.
Uh,
but the,
uh,
the,
the kind of image you form is the same.
You form a three dimensional image of objects.
But since the physics is different,
the things that create contrast or your ability to see one object from another
in an MRI image are different than in a CT image.
In a CT image.
What forms?
The contrast is the absorbance of X-ray's by the tissue and so your lungs,
which are mostly air allow x rays to pass through relatively easily and so and
so.
They're different from soft tissue like blood or the muscle tissue of your heart
which absorbs some of those rays and they're different from bone which absorbed
a lot of those x rays and so its density of the tissue absorbance of the x rays.
That leads to contrast.
One of the things I didn't talk about last time was that sometimes physicians
when they want to make images of objects where there's not a lot of intrinsic
contrast like say you want to look at the intestine,
but if you take an x ray of the abdomen,
everything appears like soft tissue.
Everything looks about the same.
If you however,
fill up the intestines with air,
if you fill up the intestines with air by feeding heir to the patient or by
somehow getting air into the intestinal track,
then that image will appear dark where that area is and you can create contrast.
You can see what's inside of the intestine that way.
Another way you can do it is by having the patient drink something that absorbs
x very readily.
And that's something is usually a solution of a Barium,
uh,
colloidal Barium solution that is very ray dense.
So you can create contrast that way.
That's a digression,
but something I didn't mention last time.
It is mentioned in the chapter.
What I want to talk about,
Mr,
is a different way of forming images uses a different kind of physics.
And so the elements of intrinsic contrast are different.
We'll talk about what makes a,
what makes a Mr images images,
um,
in,
in a few moments.
But bone does not appear well on Mri images,
whereas bone appeared very well in x rays and a cts for example.
So if you've taken chemistry,
some chemistry rather in,
in,
in college or in high school,
you've probably heard of Nmr nuclear magnetic resonance.
It was discovered by chemists as a way of,
of analyzing chemical samples.
And uh,
it turns out that if you put certain,
uh,
nuclei,
if you put certain atoms in a magnetic field,
some of them will align with the magnetic field because they have a magnetic
dipole.
Adams have a dye magnetic dipole.
So hydrogen atoms,
protons,
uh,
have an odd number of nuclei,
of neutrons or protons.
Because of that,
they have a dipole,
a magnetic dipole.
You put them in a magnetic field.
They will align with that magnetic field.
And if you then perturb the molecules that are aligned with the magnetic field
using radio frequency waves or other magnetic fields,
we'll talk about this in a moment.
Then you can measure something about the properties of the atom.
And chemists use this because it turns out that if you align all the hydrogen
atoms or protons in a sample,
if you align them in a magnetic field and then you stimulate them with the right
kind of radio frequency,
they will respond by producing a radio frequency of their own by producing an
energy emission of their own.
That energy emission is that radio frequency wave lengths and you can detect it
and protons that are in different environments will respond slightly
differently.
So a proton that is,
or a hydrogen,
I'm going to say Proton instead of hydrogen atom because that's easier to say,
or hydrogen ion,
uh,
a proton that's in a fatty solution will behave differently when stimulated in a
magnetic field and one that's in water and one that's in bone will behave even
differently than that.
So the properties that you can measure by this process called nuclear magnetic
residents depend not only on the Adam that you're stimulating hydrogen in this
case,
but the microenvironment or local surrounding that the Adam finds itself in.
And so if you talked about this in chemistry,
you might talk about distinguishing different hydrogen ions that are associated
with an alcohol molecule or with a benzene ring and how ones that are in
different positions on the molecule will actually respond differently,
give you what chemists called different chemicals shifts.
So it's that same phenomenon that's being used here to create images.
And it was discovered in 1946 that atomic nuclei could absorb.
And readmit radio frequency energy and particularly when they were aligned in a
magnetic field.
And that led to this discovery of the nuclear magnetic resonance concept led to
the Nobel Prize in physics in 1952.
It's called nuclear magnetic resonance because it involves,
um,
it depends on the particular properties of the Nuclei of atoms.
That is the number of protons,
the number of neutrons.
It's magnetic because a magnetic field is required in order to align the ions
and is called resonance because you're looking for a resonance between the,
uh,
the excitation of these molecules.
These aligned molecules aligned in a magnetic field,
which are exciting them with radio frequency waves.
And you're looking for a particular resonance between the magnetic field that's
applied and the stimulation that you give with radio frequency.
Now when I was introducing the subject,
I didn't call it nuclear magnetic resonance imaging,
I called it magnetic resonance imaging or Mri.
And that's the common name that's used for making medical images using this,
uh,
particular physical approach.
And why do you think the name was changed from nuclear magnetic residence to Mri
during the 1980s?
When this technique started to be used in people.
So anything with nuclear doesn't sound so good.
You don't want anything with nuclear done to you,
probably because of other uses of Nuclei and uh,
and concerns about nuclear sources of energy and that kind of thing.
So the name was changed,
but,
uh,
but I don't want you to be confused because the phenomenon is the same.
So to,
uh,
perform magnetic resonance and to make magnetic resonance images,
you need a very strong magnetic field.
And magnetic fields,
if you remember from physics,
are measured in a unit called Tesla.
And most of the clinical units that are used to perform magnetic resonance image
images have,
uh,
have magnetic fields ranging from 1.5 to 4.0 a Tesla.
And,
um,
uh,
Tesla,
another unit for that is the Gauss and the conversion factors shown here.
But just to put it in perspective,
you know that the earth has a magnetic field.
That's why campuses work has a magnetic field.
And so if you have a compass,
which is just a device that detects the earth's magnetic field,
always aligns with north,
for example,
the magnetic field of the earth is about 0.3,
gauss or um,
and it ranges between 0.3 and 0.6.
So a Gauss is a,
uh,
is,
that would convert to 0.6.
Gauss converts to 60 Micro Tesla,
right?
So 60 times 10 to the minus sixth Tesla
is the magnetic field of the earth.
We're talking about much,
much higher magnetic fields than that,
right?
And so,
um,
you'll need to know this because you're going to go down and visit the,
uh,
the Amr research center at Yale this afternoon.
And magnetic fields of this strength can interact with other magnetic objects
like credit cards that you might have in your pockets or keys that you have in
your pockets.
And so when you enter an Mr Suite,
you have to make sure that you're not carrying anything metal,
wearing anything metal w are carrying anything magnetize that has a risk of
being demagnetizes with it because these are very strong magnetic fields.
Because of this.
The MRF facility that you will see here at Yale is in the basement of the
Anglian Center.
And usually these,
uh,
these machines are in the basement.
So if you go to hospital and you have an Mr,
uh,
taken,
usually go down to the basement.
And why is that?
Because they're put in rooms that are specially shielded,
their specially shielded so that the magnetic fields cannot penetrate outside of
the room.
And that's so that people that are walking by in the street don't have their
credit cards erased,
right?
People that are walking by in the street don't have metal objects pulled out of
their hands right by the strong magnetic fields.
And so this is one of the risks for people that work around nuclear magnetic
resonance imaging is that the fields are so strong that any,
uh,
any metal object that's in the vicinity of the magnet can become a projectile.
And so they're very cautious about metal.
Another reason why we asked you not to take any stuff that's unnecessary with
you when you go down to the,
um,
to the,
to the amyloid center this afternoon.
So the magnetic fields are very strong.
Anybody had an MR image taken Wilma?
Yup.
Several of you.
Um,
and so it was a device might not look exactly like this,
but look,
something like this.
So this looks similar to the,
to the cat scanner I showed you last time.
And that there is an instrument with a,
uh,
basically a big cylinder with a cylindrical hole in the middle.
And this,
uh,
this whole,
this is where the patient is going to go.
The patient will be lying,
uh,
on this,
cart.
And this will act like a conveyor belt that will move the patient inside the
cylinder.
And,
um,
it's,
it's close fitting.
You don't want the size of the cylinder to be too far away from the patient
because you want the magnetic field forces and the radio waves that are emitted
by the ions.
And you're by the atoms in your body to be very close to the,
uh,
to the detectors that are measuring it.
And because of this,
when you're inside,
uh,
many people,
I don't Wilmette did you experience this?
You feel claustrophobic when you're inside the machine because you're in a very
confined space and the images take some time to acquire.
So the quality of the image depends on the strength of the magnetic field and
how long you acquire the image.
If you have more time to wait,
you can get a better image,
right?
And so there's a trade off between building magnets that are incredibly strong,
which is very expensive and a time for the patient to be inside the instrument,
to acquire an image that has a high quality.
So surrounding this,
a cylinder are coils and coils many miles of coils of wire and uh,
electrical field electricity passes through these wires in order to create a big
electromagnet.
And large magnetic fields within this,
uh,
machine.
Now the other thing about the machine is that the operator can control the
strength of the magnetic fields.
It can control stimulation of the object with radio frequency waves and it can
control what radio frequency signals it picks up from the object as well.
And one of the advantages of Mr,
we'll see a little bit more about this as we go through the physics is that it
can be tuned.
You can tune the imaging method in order to look at the kinds of things that you
would like to look at.
Okay.
And that turns out to be one of the powerful things about Mr. So people are
still discovering new ways to look at the resonance between the magnetic field
and its effect on Adams and the radio frequencies that are generated to learn
how to make new kinds of images.
And we'll talk about some of that as we go.
So the magnetic resonance that's most done in people for clinical imaging,
uh,
takes advantage of the fact that our bodies are largely water and all those
water molecules have hydrogen atoms associated with them.
And so there's a lot of hydrogen in your body and hydrogen atoms are susceptible
to magnetic resonance and they so because they contain this dipole moment that
will align in the magnetic field.
And so what happens in magnetic residence is that you're placed in a very large
magnetic field.
Many of the hydrogen nuclei in the molecules within your body align with this
And then the machine sort of tips those aligned molecules out of alignment.
And if that's done properly,
you will start a kind of motion in these molecules,
what's called a procession where the molecules move like a top.
And when they are performing this kind of motion within the magnetic field,
they're trying to get back to their preferred alignment.
But they're doing that in this top like fashion.
If you have many,
many atoms that are all processing in the right way,
they will emit radio frequency waves that you can detect in this cylinder
outside.
So this shows it sort of schematically you have Adam's inside your body.
These are,
these are a hydrogen atoms,
for example.
You place the body within a strong magnetic field and these atoms align so that
they're parallel with the magnetic field,
which is going from top to bottom.
Here you stimulate these atoms with radio frequency waves and you knock them out
of alignment.
Now you can't just stimulate them with any radio frequency wave.
That radio frequency wave has to be exactly right for the Adams that you want to
move.
It has to be,
uh,
has to be radio waves that are at the correct frequency or wavelength to
stimulate these particular,
these particular atoms.
And that's one of the things that makes mrs so,
so versatile in that if you stimulate them with one frequency,
you can manipulate hydrogen atoms.
If you stimulate them with another frequency,
you can stimulate other Adams.
Now the reason why most of the images you'll see are based on protons or
hydrogen nuclei is because hydrogen is so much more abundant than everything
else in your body.
And so you get a good signal with that.
If you are stimulating other kinds of atoms,
you wouldn't get as strong a signal.
You wouldn't be able to make as good an image.
Okay.
So you stimulate these atoms with the radio frequency.
They begin this motion or this procession,
and this just,
this just shows schematically that this procession is like a top,
they're out of alignment,
the,
the nuclear rotating and they're eventually coming back to their equilibrium
position,
which would be aligned with the magnet again.
And so what you measure in the,
uh,
in the Lmr device is this relaxation from the excited or tipped position,
relaxing back to their equilibrium or aligned position.
Now,
if you go on,
if any of you go on to study quantum mechanics or you try to study the physics
of medical imaging,
particularly Mr in more detail,
you'll,
uh,
you'll learn that this,
this simple description I gave you is not entirely accurate.
It's,
uh,
it's,
it,
it's not inaccurate,
but it doesn't describe the whole thing.
It's really a quantum mechanics phenomenon that's happening with the molecules
here.
And it can't be described completely unless you have the sort of tools of
quantum physics to describe it.
But this is a sufficient way of thinking about,
uh,
the,
what's going on in here.
So what you measured then is the relaxation of these excited molecules back to
their align state.
And you can measure that because as these molecules are processing,
they're emitting radio frequency radiation,
which you can detect now.
So this involves magnetic fields,
strong magnetic fields.
It involves radio frequency radiation,
the kind of radiation that uh,
that radio stations used to broadcast signals that are picked up by antennas,
right?
And so these are generally presumed to be safe for biological tissues.
There is no ill effects that we know of,
have exposure to,
uh,
to exposure to magnetic fields or radio frequency radiation at these
wavelengths.
And so it doesn't have the same concerns that x ray radiation or other kinds of
radiation,
which I'll talk about a few minutes have.
So this is some examples of Mr Images.
These are Mr images that are taken at different locations in the,
in the brain.
And remember now that the patient is being,
is being conveyed on this table into the core of the instrument.
And measurements are made only on the part of the body that's inside the
instrument.
And so just like in CT image,
you move the patient through and you take images of different slices through the
patient.
Right now if,
uh,
if the patient is having a,
a brain or a head Mr Scan,
you would just put them in until you went through this part of the body.
If you're doing it in the abdomen or the leg,
you would just scan that part of the body.
And this shows,
this shows then images,
transverse images at various locations.
Moving down,
this is,
this is a near the top of the head.
This is a little further down.
You can see the ventricles,
I think actually these two images might be the s from the same location,
but they show you one of the features of Mr that is by looking at different
relaxations or stimulating with different pulses of radio frequency,
you can see different kinds of contrast.
So in this image you can see more clearly the distinction between gray matter
and white matter.
In this image,
you don't see that so clearly,
but you see better the distinction between brain tissue and the cerebral spinal
fluid that's in the ventricles.
So the,
the,
the point is that the,
that the technique can be tuned to see what you would like to see best.
Right.
And then going farther down in the brain,
you see now you're seeing some of the bones of the,
of the face and the cerebellum back here or a lower section of the brain.
So this is a section probably from somewhere in here and this is even lower down
than that.
Okay.
So these are just examples of some magnetic residence images.
As I mentioned,
magnetic residence is not so good at looking at bone because bone doesn't have a
lot of water in it.
It doesn't have a lot of,
so it doesn't contribute a lot of signal,
but it's very good for looking at differences between soft tissues.
And remember in CT soft tissues like the muscular wall of the heart and the
blood that's inside the heart look roughly the same and you can't distinguish
those.
Well there's not intrinsic contrast with Mr. There is intrinsic contrast because
those prop,
the properties of those different tissues are,
are different.
Uh,
by this method.
A newer form of magnetic resonance imaging is called a functional Mri imaging
and it uses the same machine.
It uses the same approach,
but instead of designing your radio frequency pulses so that you look at the
static structure,
you design it so that you're particularly sensitive for looking at flowing blood
and uh,
and you can actually measure the velocity of blood flow in different regions of
the brain.
Now you can do that because blood contains a lot of water and this is water
that's not static,
just staying in one place in the brain,
but it's moving through blood vessels and you can detect the motion of the blood
vessels with this,
uh,
with this technique,
it can also tell the difference between saturated and de Saturated blood.
What saturated blood here,
I mean blood that's saturated with oxygen.
So it's loaded up with oxygen,
desaturated blood,
his blood that's had the oxygen removed.
Now if you can measure blood flow and you can measure differences between
saturated and desaturated blood,
that means that you can monitor within a small region of tissue how much blood
flow is going through,
how much oxygen is being consumed,
so you can measure locally what's the rate of oxygen consumption in a tissue.
Now,
if you know oxygen consumption,
then you know something about metabolic activity in that tissue.
A region of tissue that's consuming a lot of oxygen is doing a lot of work right
in the brain.
If you find regions of tissue that are consuming oxygen,
that means those are regions of tissue where there's a lot of energy being
consumed.
Those are regions of tissue where there's a lot of neural activity,
a lot of brain cells doing what brain cells do,
right?
So it's called functional Mri imaging.
Because through this approach,
one can look inside the brain,
for example,
and find regions that are performing functions.
So an experiment that,
well,
the other thing about Fmr I,
before I talk about the experiment is that instead of just looking at anatomy,
now this is a high resolution picture of the anatomy of brain and Fmr.
I images fuzzier.
You don't have as high a resolution and that's because you want to take images
fast.
You want to take images fast,
you don't want to wait a long time and you want to be see,
you want to see how the image changes with time,
right?
In a static image.
When they took a picture of Wilma for example,
they kept her inside the machine for awhile so that they could get a really high
resolution image of the structure in her brain,
but she was asked to remain very still because you don't want to have any
motion.
You want just a picture of the statics and Fmr.
I you,
you want to take a picture faster,
but then you want to look at how it changes with time because it's these changes
in time that allow you to look at things like oxygen consumption.
You have to look over time in order to measure that,
right?
So in an Fmri,
in one kind of FM Ri imaging,
you look at blood oxygen level,
that's a measure of neural activity.
When blood oxygen goes up,
a neural activity goes up,
the extraction of oxygen goes up and the I signal goes up.
So here's an example of an Fmri image and actually the,
the Fmr images and shown here,
the FMRI image would be a blurry one,
like the one I showed you in the last slide.
But you might find regions where there's high levels of activity,
high levels of activity,
and you were in super impose those on a static image of that same brain.
So here are two kinds of imaging were done.
One was the high resolution,
Mr Imaging to get a picture of the anatomy and then this more rapid time
sequence of images to find out where oxygen consumption was occurring.
And what was discovered was that oxygen consumption is occurring in this
location here and this location here,
and this is known to be a,
uh,
a certain area of the brain called Broca's area that's involved in a speech.
Um,
I don't remember whether it's in,
in,
um,
in hearing and decoding speech or in producing speech.
I think in hearing and decoding speech,
but I don't remember in this particular example,
mixed speech was,
uh,
was,
while the patient was being image,
they were being exposed to a speech that included a mixture of languages,
both Spanish and English.
In this picture,
they were only listening to Spanish.
In this picture there were only listening to English.
And what you see is that when they're the mixed under the mixed condition,
when they're hearing both Spanish and English,
there's a certain portion of the brain that's more active than it is with only
Spanish and only English.
And from this you could,
can conclude that this part of the brain must be involved somehow in the special
activity that was happening at this point here.
That is some kind of a mixed language experience and many,
many,
this is this.
As you could extrapolate from this and you could imagine that this approach
where you could look at what areas of the brain become active during certain
sorts of activities,
certain sorts of behavior when certain emotions are elicited has become a very
powerful tool in psychology.
So you can do psychological experiments while patients are getting Fmri scans
and you can find out what parts of the brain are involved in that kind of
psychological response.
And so this imaging is teaching us a lot more than just what is the normal
structure of tissue in this case the brain looks like,
but how does it really work in a functioning animal like a person.
So that's a very brief introduction to,
to,
to Mr Imaging.
There's a lot more to learn about this.
You'll learn more about this and you'll see some of these instruments this
afternoon.
And um,
and uh,
there's more detail in the book as well.
A second kind of imaging which shares and advantage with Mr with Mr in that it
does not involve a ionizing radiation is ultrasound imaging and ultrasound
imaging is different from the others we've talked about in that there is no
electromagnetic radiation involved.
You're not using light or different forms of light.
Here.
You're using sound to create images in stead and sound is pressure waves that
transmit through a medium.
When I'm talking up here,
my vocal apparatus is creating waves of pressure in the air which get
transmitted through the room,
right?
And you can understand them because the waves of preset pressure that I'm
creating stimulate your eardrums at the right frequencies and you convert that
into sound.
Ultrasound uses much,
much higher frequencies of sound than our ears can detect,
right?
So we detect,
I forget exactly what the range is,
but up to,
um,
up to I think 40,000 hertz or,
or cycles per second is the frequency.
And this is in the megahertz range or millions of hertz range.
So it's,
it's higher frequency sounds.
Then you can hear.
So some have very short of these,
uh,
of these,
of these high frequency sound waves have very a short wave lengths and so they
can penetrate through tissues and ultrasound allows for good imaging of
anatomical structure and it's also a fast imaging method.
And so it can allow you to look at motion in ways that are difficult to do using
some of these other techniques.
And I'll,
I'll tell you about that.
So the way that ultrasound works is you have to get sound waves propagated into
the body and you do that through a special device called an ultrasound
transducer and the transducer is placed right on the surface of your body.
It might look like a cylinder,
like a probe that's placed against the surface of your body and usually not even
just placed against the surface of your body,
but it's placed with some kind of a gel or a liquid gel such that the probe
comes in very good contact with your skin.
And that's because sound waves don't transmit very easily across interfaces,
right?
If I put something up between my voice and you then,
then the sound waves don't transmit as well,
right?
You can't hear it.
Sound waves bounce off interfaces.
So you want to get the sound to go into the skin,
you have to put the transducer,
which is producing the sound waves right up against the skin,
and you don't want a gap of air in between.
And that's why you put the Gel.
Okay?
Now this transducer has a special material in it that's called a pizo electric
material.
And Pizo Electric materials have the property that if you put a voltage through
them,
they,
they resonate or they physically move.
And in addition,
if you stimulate a pas electric material with a,
with a moving wave,
it will,
it will create a voltage.
So voltages get transmitted into movements.
And in this transducer,
the movement gets transmitted into sound way is what produces the sound waves
that get transmitted into your skin and through your body.
The transmit because these pizo electric materials can both can both form sound
when they're stimulated and they can detect sound and converted into
electricity.
When they're stimulated by sound,
then the transducer is both sending out sound waves and receiving sound waves
back,
right?
So these work basically by the same principle that an that an echo works.
If I,
if I shout
in the right kind of a room where there's nothing to absorb the sound between me
and the back wall,
the sound,
we'll hit the back wall and it will be reflected back to me and I will hear that
sound some time interval later.
But you've all had the experience of hearing an echo.
The same thing happens here.
You transmit sound into the skin and it moves forward until it hits an interface
and sound doesn't move so well across interfaces,
right?
So a moose to your skin and it goes down and it hits the bone.
There's an interface between materials here that have two different properties,
skin,
muscle,
bone,
and in each one of those interfaces,
some of the sound bounces back.
And since the detector is most sending sound and receiving sound,
it sends out a sound wave and then it gets the sound back and it can determine
how long it took for the sound to come back.
Right?
If I know the speed of sound and I know how long it took for an echo to return,
I can calculate how far away the object was that created the echo or the
interference.
Right?
So ultrasound works by sending out sound waves that bounce back are received and
the machine calculates how long it took for this echo to go out and come back.
And then it knows there must've been some kind of an object at that distance
away.
Does that make sense?
So ultrasound mesh creates echo time maps and,
and calculates depths from that.
Okay.
I'm sorry,
I'm having lots of technical issues today.
Okay.
Something happened,
right?
So here's an ultrasound image of the heart and it's the heart turned upside
down.
So this is,
this is vaguely familiar to you from from a few weeks ago,
but um,
the um,
the atria are on the top and the event or the [inaudible] on the bottom and the
ventricles are on the top.
And that's just to show you it in alignment with this image here.
And so the probe is placed on the chest for example,
and it's moved from side to side at one location.
And so what you see is an image of what the probe can see as it moves,
as it sort of sweeps out this cone where the sound is moving and what you see is
that there are boundaries between light and dark regions here and those
correspond to boundaries in the tissue.
And so you can see the right atrium,
you can see the right ventricle.
Over here you can see the left atrium and the left ventricle because the white
region is the muscular tissue of the heart and the darker region is the blood
that's within the heart.
Now you'll notice that it's kind of a,
it's not a sharp image like the images that I showed you with CT or the images
that I showed you with Mr. It's a noisier image and there are,
there's a lot of sort of white spots or dark spots,
spots throughout it and those are things that are called speckles.
These are talked about in your book,
but there are random sources of,
of interference with the ultrasound image.
The reason why ultrasound is useful is because you can watch things with time
and so you can see motion in static pictures.
It looks like a very noisy image.
But if you are watching this in real time,
you would see the motion of the heart and the speckles wouldn't be as obvious
because you'd be noticing more how the walls of this,
uh,
of the ventricle move for example,
in time.
And that would be very clear from the image.
What would also be clear to you is the motion of the valves.
And we talked about the very critical role that valves play in the function of
your heart.
If your valves aren't working right,
you can't make an efficient heartbeat.
That is a heartbeat that produces a cardiac output.
And so and so ultrasound imaging has been one of the,
one of the most used tools for looking at valve disease in that event it's
called Echo cardiography.
You ever heard of that term?
Echocardiography,
which is basically ultrasound of the heart and it's used principally to look at
the function of your valve,
the mitral valve and tricuspid valve here.
If this was a video image,
you would see the valance opening and closing in correct coordination,
hopefully with the contraction of the heart.
So ultrasound allows you to,
to,
to look at motion and so to see things that are moving,
uh,
that would be difficult to do with other techniques.
You also know,
and probably all of you in this room have,
were,
were pictures were taken of you when you were in utero.
And ultrasound imaging is a very common form of fetal monitoring.
Now,
uh,
where almost every woman who is pregnant has at least one ultrasound image taken
at some course during the pregnancy just to make sure that the pregnancy is
proceeding properly.
And this is an example of an ultrasound image.
It looks the same way and ultrasound image of an infant.
This is the kind of machine,
the ultrasound imaging machine that you might find in,
in,
in obstetrics,
uh,
um,
office.
And,
uh,
you can see in this particular case that,
here's the head of the fetus.
Here's an arm,
here's the torso.
Again,
it's not a very sharp image.
Uh,
but if you were watching this in real time as the technician move the probe
around on the pregnant woman's abdomen,
you would see the,
the baby moving and you would be able to distinguish parts much more easily in
that way because you're moving both the probe and the baby's moving and you're
seeing things from different angles in real time as it's happening.
So this is a very,
a common technique.
I wouldn't be surprised if many of you,
if you don't have a picture of yourself in Utero,
in your scrapbook,
probably your mother has one somewhere.
Um,
all,
uh,
infants,
of your age where,
uh,
where we're ultrasound.
Ultrasound is also a good technique for looking at flow.
And when you look at flow,
you're taking advantage of something called the doppler effect and you've in
physics probably heard about the doppler effect.
Uh,
a simple way of thinking about it as if you're standing on the street and
there's,
uh,
there's an ambulance coming towards you or a car that's coming towards you and
the horn is honking.
As the car is approaching you,
you hear a certain frequency of sound that changes as the car passes.
The frequency of the sound that you hear depends both on the frequency of the
sound that's being emitted by the siren and the speed that the ambulance is
moving relative to you.
So when the,
when the ambulance is moving towards you,
you hear a frequency that's offset from the real frequency of the siren.
What's moving away from you?
It's offset even more.
Right?
And you can hear that.
And so if I'm doing ultrasound imaging,
imaging with sound waves of an object that's moving away from the probe,
I can detect both where it is and how fast it's moving by the frequency of the
signal that's returned to the probe.
Okay.
And that allows you to image the rate of blood flow through vessels.
And that's shown in this picture here.
So you can measure the rate of blood flow through the carotid arteries,
for example.
And that turns out to be a very useful technique for patients that have a
cerebrovascular disease.
They're getting atherosclerosis or hardening of the arteries in the important
vessels going up to their neck that can be measured through their neck,
up to their brain.
That can be measured using ultrasound.
Okay.
So those two methods,
magnetic resonance ultrasound have the big advantage that,
um,
that they don't involve ionizing radiation.
Magnetic resonance imaging in general takes a long time,
requires very expensive equipment.
Ultrasound imaging can be done in real time.
You can take pictures,
images of the inside rapidly.
The,
the equipment is not so expensive.
So any doctor's office can have an ultrasound machine.
Um,
the image quality is not as high,
but you can image things that are in motion,
right?
So there's,
so these,
these imaging,
uh,
approaches are used for different applications because of the advantages that
each one has.
Okay.
I want to talk briefly about nuclear medicine and I'm going to have to go
fast here.
Uh,
about nuclear.
And this does use a form of ionizing radiation.
In particular gamma rays.
Gamma rays are produced by nuclear events events inside the nucleus.
In particular,
they happen when radioactive isotopes decay.
When radioactive isotopes,
like a xenon one 33,
technetium 99,
iodine one 2023.
These are unstable isotopes of these molecules.
And so with a certain frequency,
they will decay back to their more stable form.
When they decay,
they emit a form of radiation called gamma radiation.
Many of these and gamma rays,
you remember on the electromagnetic spectrum,
they were up there with x rays.
High frequency,
short wavelength radiation penetrates easily through tissue,
but is also an example of ionizing radiation.
Now the difference between nuclear medicine and what's called nuclear medicine
and conventional x rays is in x-rays.
The X ray source was outside of you and you were being bombarded with x rays in
nuclear medicine.
The Ex,
the,
the gamma ray source is injected inside of you.
And what you measure is the amount of radiation that comes out.
Now what's the advantage of that?
Well,
the advantage is if I can find radio isotopes that concentrate in certain
regions of your body and I inject those isotopes into you and then measure where
they are,
I can measure the function of that particular region of your body.
And the first imaging that was done was done in the thyroid.
And your thyroid actually has a very,
uh,
active mechanism for concentrating iodine.
And because of that,
if I feed somebody radioactive iodine,
that iodide will accumulate in their thyroid gland,
which is in your neck.
And the rate at which it accumulates.
And the pattern at which it accumulates can indicate whether you have a healthy
or a or a disease,
thyroid.
And if I then take images of the thyroid after I've injected the radioactivity
and I looked to see if the radio activities there and how fast it gets there and
how fast your body removes it,
then I can learn something about how your thyroid is functioning because of its
ability to concentrate iodine.
That's one example of it,
but imagine you have a chemical that accumulates in the brain and accumulates
only in certain areas.
For example,
you have a,
you have a chemical that's related to the neurotransmitter dopamine and you give
it to a patient that you suspect of having Parkinson's disease or Parkinson's
disease involves the brain neurons that process and use dopamine.
And so if this radio chemical goes up into the brain,
it's going to interact with those cells that are involved in Parkinson's
disease.
By watching how this molecule moves around in the brain,
I can learn about how your brain is processing dopamine and if it's responding
in a normal sort of way.
Right?
Does that make sense?
So the advantage of nuclear medicine is that you're designing very specific
kinds of radioactive molecules that you can put into the body.
The molecules are designed to eliminate some kind of biological function,
not structure.
And then I measure the time course of how those objects,
how those radio labeled compounds move through your body.
Um,
there are several ways of measuring it.
I'm just going to show you the simple one here.
Um,
not simple one,
but a very powerful one called positron emission tomography.
And here the,
uh,
the chemical that's admitted is a special radio isot tro tope that emits not
gamma rays but,
but another.
Um,
but another,
uh,
um,
nuclear,
another particle called a positron.
And when positrons are admitted,
they will move through tissue until they hit an electron.
But positive trends don't have to move very far.
There's lots of electrons around in a,
in tissues and win a positron hits an electron,
they annihilate one another and they generate to gamma rays which move in
opposite directions.
And so if I have a positron emitting substance in the brain,
it will emit gamma rays,
which can be detected.
And because I'm detecting one here and one here,
I know exactly where the source came from.
Right?
I can trace it back along the lines where I detected the gamma rays and I can
find out where the positron emitting element was.
And so I can make very nice maps of the brain like these that show you where the
positron emitting isotope accumulates in the brain.
And this is called pet imaging.
Um,
I'm going to skip over this one which tells you a little bit about the economics
of these different modalities.
Ultrasound,
as I mentioned,
was cheaper CT cost more Mr in general costs more pet imaging costs even more
because you have to generate radio isotopes locally at the source too.
And so in general you need a cyclotron or some kind of a machine to generate
these radio isotopes as well.
And there are other things you have to think about if you're thinking about,
uh,
installing these is how much do they cost to operate and how,
um,
how,
how much does it cost to operate,
how heavily do technicians have to be involved in order to keep them working?
The last thing I want to talk about his optical imaging.
And as I mentioned last time,
I think that during your lifetime we're gonna see a lot new,
a PR of new approaches for using light to image inside the body.
That's a problem,
right?
Because light doesn't penetrate through your body.
It bounces off,
most of it bounces off.
And that's why we can see each other because we're seeing the reflected light
off of a different objects.
Uh,
but uh,
but you can use,
um,
you can use a light to look at biological objects and you can look at them in
great detail this way.
And that's what microscopes do.
They allow you to use light radiation in order to look at magnified images of a
biological objects.
And we've gotten very good at designing microscopes that allow us to look at in
very sophisticated ways that biological objects on the stage of a microscope.
And this just shows you an image.
It's actually very similar to the,
to the CT scans or Mri Scans I showed you before.
And that these are different optical sections taken from a pollen grain.
Appalling grain is very small,
right?
But,
and here's an image from the bottom,
moving up,
moving up.
This shows you all the three dimensional detail of this particular,
uh,
pollen grain.
You can reconstruct in three dimensions and see what it looks like on the
outside or you could look and see what it's like at any point in its interior
structure.
We're very sophisticated it using light to make images like this.
Now on microscope stages and one can take very beautiful pictures of biological
objects like cells with different kinds of optical techniques.
Here is um,
this is familiar to you.
This is a gold medalist and I told you what it [inaudible] was last week,
but this shows sort of the tuft of capillaries inside of [inaudible] image by
light microscopy.
Well,
how do I take advantage of this kind of microscopy?
But look at these kinds of images inside people.
Well,
we don't know how to do that yet,
but we do have some technologies for looking at using light to look inside.
And the main one is called endoscopy.
And endoscopy involves objects called fiber optics and fiber optics allow you to
not only focus light through a lens,
but to take that light and bounce it down and optical shaft,
right?
So I could take a light beam and shine it here into a fiber.
That fiber has a special coating on it,
which then allows the light to bounce all the way down the,
the uh,
the fiber.
I can bend the fiber and because the bouncing depends on the coding and not the
shape of the fiber,
the light will turn with the fiber,
right?
This south fiber optics work is described a little bit more detail in your book.
And so one can design devices like this endoscope and this endoscope,
you can look through this end here.
It has a light source and that light source shines through fiber optics that,
uh,
that you can bend around and that light comes out the outside.
If the light comes out the outside,
it hits some biological object and then bounces back.
Light reflects light and you can see it.
And so you can look inside objects where you can put this endoscope.
So this end descope is designed to go,
you know,
a patient will swallow it.
And so this end will go down in their mouth,
past their vocal cords,
through their esophagus,
into the stomach,
and then out of the stomach into the duodenum or the first part of the small
intestine.
And that's what's shown here.
This is the valve,
this leading from the stomach into the duodenum or the first part of the,
of the small intestine.
And you can see what the lining of the small intestine in the stomach looks
like.
And so this has been a very important,
uh,
diagnostic approach for using light to image the lining of the stomach.
What would you be looking for?
Things like ulcers,
things like cancers,
any kind of disturbance in the normal anatomy of the,
of the lining of the gut.
And I think you're going to see a lot of new methods beyond this for using light
to look inside people as well.
I'll stop there.
Thanks.